kerry bonjour alors jean castex avait un
agenda chargé ce matin qu'en est il du
plan de relance qu'il doit annoncer en
début d'après-midi les paires pour ce
qui est de ce plan de relance il s'agit
pour le gouvernement que vous l'a
annoncé de préparer 2030 est allé au
delà du seul rebond de l'économie une
économie fortement affaiblie par la
crise sanitaire et le comique 19 ce plan
ne se contente pas de panser les plaies
de la crise ils préparent l'avenir c'est
ce qu'a expliqué le premier ministre
jean castex à nos confrères du figaro
hier mercredi
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
retrouver en 2022 le niveau d'activité
d'avant la crise alors que j'ai commencé
peut-être avoir une reprise une baisse
du chômage alors que 800 1000 nouveaux
emplois devraient être supprimés cette
année 100 milliards d'euros dont qui
devraient être injectés dans l'économie
française sur deux ans alors que le pib
français devrait se contracter d'au
moins 11% cette année en raison du
confinement notamment et après les 460
milliards d'euros de soutien d'urgence
mobilisées depuis le début de la crise
le plan de relance de jean castex est un
plan à sur le moyen terme et il
s'exprimera plus précisément d'ici
quelques minutes de l'hôtel matignon